the quality of outcome it's impossible
if you pursue it you end up with a
dystopia and even if it were possible it
would not be desirable for the reasons
you point to about the benefits of what
you're calling competition and I would
want to tear competition into a couple
different values there's true
competition against yourself you know
you you're skiing down the slope and
you're paying attention to how you're
doing and you're trying to do it better
than you've done it before right and
there's competition against others and
the thing that unites those two things
is that the what you are trying to
accomplish is real it it is the world
telling you how successful you are at
something directly rather than through
some sort of social channel some sort of
reward handed to you or some compliment
given to you by somebody and there's a
tremendous danger in a socially mediated
world in which those who are successful
are successful because some social thing
has told them that they are correct
because you can be dead wrong seem
correct and move ahead in a social world
whereas if you're doing carpentry if
you're in some sort of competition the
nature of the beast is one that will
tell you when you've got it wrong and
therefore it will allow you to actually
improve your insight in whatever form
you have it so I'm a tremendous fan of
the idea that even if your world is
largely socially mediated you have to
make sure that some part of it isn't and
you know you are confronting something
real enough to tell you when you're
confused so that you can learn how not
to be confused but there are people in
this world that do want to push towards
an equality of outcome yes and they they
make it sound as if this is not just
logical but ethical and possible in the
future and that you are on the wrong
side of history if you if you think that
capitalism and competition and all these
things you just talked about are good
and that really that the best thing is
to force people to become some sort of
utopian creature that works together in
unison and and everybody is egalitarian
and there's no need for feminism
men's rights activists because everybody
looks at everyone isn't equal well there
are two kinds of people who will
advocate for equality of outcome one
kind of person who will is confused they
don't understand what happens if you go
down this road and the other one is
cynical and they're using this as an
excuse to justify something that just so
happens to reward them but equality of
opportunity isn't this way it solves all
of those problems nobody believes that
you're going to have it ever realized in
a perfect forum there's always going to
be bad luck that's going to reduce
somebody's opportunity what you don't
want is any systemic bias in luck in
other words we're all going to suffer
some bad luck and we'll all have some
good luck and some of those things will
actually shape the trajectory of our
lives what you don't want is some
population that just so happens to
suffer more than its share of bad luck
which is what we we have now